[Music]
good morning guys today is a Sunday
morning a beautiful sunny Sunday morning
and we are house shopping so finally the
time has come where we feel that we've
saved up enough or we can actually
afford a down payment in this crazy
California housing market that is
insanely expensive luckily we have been
trying to put little pennies away here
and there and now we're like hey you
know what maybe we can't afford a home
now so today we're gonna be meeting up
with Barton Geo's realtor Kevin who if
you guys watch Barton Geo's blogs you
will already know and met him already
but he's super awesome really really
nice and super professional and he's a
he I love hook he has our best interest
in mind and so we're gonna meet up with
him right now and today we're seeing
five homes as leasing houses home same
thing but don't get all like high
expectation on us we are not Barton Gio
we don't make that kind of money we're
not gonna be viewing mansions at home so
they're very humble homes okay so yeah
we're pulling up right now here's Casey
he's driving and then Isaac's in the
back seat how are you feeling baby
because I actually had to take him to
Urgent Care yesterday his ear was in a
lot of pain I felt way better yeah yeah
we got you some antibiotics and some
painkillers you're feeling good alright
we're here we're gonna go look at some
homes
[Music]
oh my goodness you said you wanted a
house at the pool yes right now there's
even a diving board so oh nice any new
pool be built now will not allow for a
diving board so those amazingly
grandfathered in so this third car
garage yeah yeah oh you guys went to
that one class yeah I could park my bike
here yeah they're like eject good last
weekend real sis awesome homes but this
time we're like oh we should be walking
different memories that's what you guys
are with us here but the other homes we
saw they were crazy
[Music]
don't you think you've seen so many
houses amazing because there's another
place that we're like this close up
putting an offer that this might
actually be competing with in my mind
because the other one is like brand
brand-new
alright so we just viewed a home that
was freaking dope but I didn't want to
film in there because I just feel really
weird filming other people's things cuz
the people still live there so we'll
only show you guys the empty homes that
we get to see today but this house it is
a lot further than we want to go but
that house is pretty cool it is smaller
inside but the backyard had a pool ahead
like this crazy extra land where you can
build more if you wanted to and it had
like its own little like they call it
like a she shed where you could pretty
much make it like into a room except it
doesn't have a closet but Isaac's like
yeah this is where I would live and
everybody has a tiny little porch it was
so cute
and then I had a swingset it's a heated
pool and I had like a back yard barbecue
area - or was so dying so this family
here like they end up entertaining a lot
but they don't have kids and you could
tell because the inside of the house is
so small that one of the bedrooms it was
a three bedroom one of the bedrooms the
girl actually changed it into her closet
because the actual master bedroom
doesn't have a lot of closet space we
are trying to you know potentially start
our family add new members to our family
and that house was just smaller than
what I want for you know how many men
family members we want to add and just
yeah i imagining everyone growing up
there it's gonna get very cramped very
soon even though there the backyard is
amazing and yeah i don't know it's just
a lot of times you when you go into
these houses like they they build the
houses for one intention and that
intention has done so well that you're
like oh yeah this could totally be us
too and then you know but then you walk
down you're like oh yeah you know what
back to reality it's not what I want
yeah it's you know we're doing the
family thing so these are the type of
things that we're considering when we're
making such an important big purchase
like buying a home because especially
since this is our first home we're like
we really want to shop and make sure
that we're getting
saying that we can get the best bang for
our buck by the way side note KC forgot
to bring the actual cameras card so
we're filming all this right now on my
phone I'm so stupid
yeah so that's why this footage is
insanely shaky so yeah we started house
shopping maybe like a month ago now so
there's been multiple weekends where
we've already done you know a lot of
walkthroughs and stuff and I think all
three of us have pretty much kind of
found our number one contender but you
know it's good the thing is that number
one contender that we really liked is it
was the very first place that we saw so
that gets us nervous falling in love
with the very first place that you see
because then you feel like you're not
making a very sound decision when you
haven't looked at other options so
that's why we continue to look at other
homes to make sure we have other options
and we're like okay for sure that first
place we want is still like contender
number 100 s1 this next one we're going
to is a gated community and that excites
me excite - yeah
why what's so cool about gated
communities feel safer you feel safer
yeah there's like extra measures taken
already
to prevent bad people from getting in so
true nowadays is just smart to have a
security system
cameras put in place which we already
have at our current place we have
cameras so that already makes me feel
safe but a gated community though it's
like that added security that you can't
get from a non gated community dude your
Tesla ceiling looks dope I know I love
this this is so cool by the way another
side note let me show you guys what I
did to my car what'd you do look what I
did
so this car comes with this shiny black
like cheap view plastic looking thing
I'm the model 3 but I ended up wrapping
it so it could be a matte white and it
matches this that already came with the
car and this and the seats in the seat
and I also added some red T's all over
the car even on the outside I put a red
teeth so I made it a little bit fancier
I'll show you guys I added them to the
wheels to the camera ain't that nice
all right today the photos yeah there's
no carpet
[Music]
pretty good shower so when you shower
together pull a pantry in the bathroom
[Music]
all right so this one staged is what
they call it in the real estate business
so we're not filming other people's
things that makes me feel better
seek and you get Apple oh my god can we
put an offer here for this place yeah
you see little house like this I read
this really sells me
[Music]
that's yours closer to the clothes what
are you doing behind the wheel Isaac I'm
driving honey
I'm certain police regiment that is very
surprising because you thought just
kidding so we spent the whole day
driving around town visiting different
homes different properties to check out
and we ate up a lot of the charged I was
in the battery of the Tesla so now we
are parked and waiting for the car the
charge no mommy I'm Sunni and I'm losing
sorry baby
you know you're just not as good as
mommy you know first place baby you're
sick please I love him this is my actual
car though they're using my card as the
little true avatar thingy I think I
mentioned this earlier today but Isaac's
been fighting an ear ache they didn't
call it an ear infection but they did
give him antibiotics so again
technically it is an ear infection I
don't know I'm just the reason why I'm
hesitant to call it that is because the
doctor didn't actually call it an ear
infection called it an ear ache so
anyway he's not feeling too good so
after he was being a trooper
you were high-five to that I remember
like two nights ago it hurts so bad -
crane there Florian Oh crazy no I watch
the Sun come up
Oh crazy that's beautiful do that do
that
was that a nice consolation prize for
the thing it was actually that's good
actually actually actually you know what
actually sucks
naturally sucks me actually sorry Ashley
[Laughter]
actually sucks about me being sick what
it's me having this ear infection
ruining me to eat yeah he has lost of
that but I still have a fever
do you he does it here's a little warm
though I did have a fever this morning
though hmm
but that did actually that actually
Ashley let me tell you girl she did that
hurt
that prevented me from eating too so it
was really hard to eat but I ended up
getting hungry like hungry when we're
not eating yeah yeah
even when you were hungry like you would
get nauseous to lunch earlier so I'm
like that's more than just an earring I
don't know that's like a that's like a
tummy ache - yeah now we're just gonna
watch Isaac play Halo yeah oh yeah hey
by the way if the people have spoken
oh they want video game videos video
game videos please gameplays up he knows
life streams you want a live stream your
live stream you rather like live stream
than make gameplay videos no just play
videos and then live stream and their
live stream so you do gameplay videos
and then after you should do some live
streams I see teach me your ways obi-wan
[Music]
how do you feel about doing your own
laundry now
nothing your older I feel like we need a
write a piece of paper uh-huh that tells
us what we need to do yeah I do you
always forget how did you laundry
usually when I do laundry he's always
gone okay and so this time I'm like dude
you're home I'm doing laundry you're
doing your own laundry feel like skill
to have
yeah man I was watching my own clothes
always said that's awesome you know how
old I was when I started washing my
clothes
I see College I know I can tell it's a
good life skill to have start practicing
now I'm my responsibility
raising a man here to be a responsible
man not a man that relies on his wife to
do everything for him that you get to
cook so that's why you're forgiven and
all other aspects of making it home you
cook so I handle everything sweet that's
a good deal
[Music]
that's good you used to think that was
the liquid inside gushers and I always
wanted to eat it gushers liquid right
there that's gusher cooks I can do that
looks good looks delicious though I know
when they have vitamin deficiencies they
crave laundry detergent that crazy and
they creep dirt road dirt does look like
Oreo crumbs though you know the real
test comes after they come out of the
dryer and you're folding them and
putting them away no no dude no sir
you're doing them yours oh I'm not
holding your stuff anymore you know what
though a lot of the homes that we've
been liking I don't know why but the
design of those what I think you know
how to do laundry yes second child can
you please pick up your clothes right in
the hamper this one is this the Darsh
you know how many times you ask me which
ones the darts and which ones alight and
how many years of the ride the temper
this is the darts I'm sure of it cuz the
lights are over there beer where this is
all fall yeah the lights guys your woman
will nag because you give her a reason
to neck if you don't want to hear the
nagging don't give her a reason to nag
just listen and be a good boy and that's
it
PSA is over see so easy
yes it's very easy to just listen high
five steam good teamwork yep well work
if you listened I love you so back to
what I was saying a lot of the homes
that we've been looking at I don't know
what the designs are like
but the laundry room is right next to
whose room think me mean you're doing
laundry boy yeah you get excited
Oh cute you gotta figure yeah oh this is
grown-up stuff all right I am down you
know when you're a kid grown-up stuff is
so freaking fun I remember when I was
younger I'd be like what I get to go to
the laundromat and put the coins in the
machine because I was poor I didn't have
my own laundry room in my house and all
this like oh this is fun I get to fold
all the family's clothes this is nice oh
I got to wash dishes I like that we do
the way you move makes it you make it
seem like it's so proper it's like mmm
Pinkie Pie yes I do everything very like
very very happy with it
very sophisticated very ladylike thank
you you want to play games
yeah you want to play games
me yet I'm down I'm so down you guys
wanna have three player halo
oh yeah but you guys gonna have Nintendo
switch game plays - I love playing crash
bandicoot no the one that I love
what's the call mr. call with the call
with the car overcooked
I love playing overcooked that's fun I
think that'd be a really fun video to
make gameplay video game that we get to
play with eggs like overcooked and then
Super Smash Bros I'm down to play that
too
oh we all get rekt though by you I know
you're really good in that game Super
Smash Bros that's my game make a seat
turn off the camera so we can enjoy a
family time together
bye bye bye guys didn't deserve to look
up bye guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]